momente von schwerer krankheit und not sind
oft auch momente von existenziellen fragen
die auseinandersetzung mit dem sinn des lebens
etwa nachdem bei seinem trägt und wer man ist
solche fragen und ungewissheiten löst jeder
anders aber nicht selten spielt die religion
dabei eine rolle in der schweiz kommt in solchen
situationen schon seit mehreren jahren spiritual
care zum zuge aber schließt man damit nicht jene
aus die mit spiritualität nichts am hut haben
darüber spreche ich jetzt mit zwei frauen die
es wissen müssen diese wellen not professorin
für seelsorge und ulrike towson humanistische
beraterin guten morgen schön dass sie da sind
ja sie beide sind ja expertinnen wenn es
darum geht schwierige gespräche zu beginnen
und deswegen frage ist ja auch gleich selber wo
und wie beginnt man eigentlich richtig vernarrt
ein schwieriges gespräch beginnt man mit einer
guten vorbereitung das heißt es geht darum sich
zuerst zu vergewissern bin ich imstande bin ich
wirklich bereit diese personen meine ungeteilte
aufmerksamkeit zukommen zu lassen das ist der
erste schritt war 1000 was ist ihre meinung wie
begegnen sie ein gutes gespräch kann frau
not durchaus zustimmen gute vorbereitung
vor allem in der hinsicht dass die eigene
einstellung betrifft also dass innerhalb
beim eigenen gemütszustand ist sehr sehr wichtig
abgesehen davon ist natürlich aber kann man sich
nie 100 prozentig auf das jeweilige gespräche
vorbereiten und man nie ganz genau weiß was
was einem begegnen wird wer einen begegnen wird
aber wenn man die eigene einstellung wenn man die
wenn die stimmt hat man schon viel erreicht
ich persönlich finde auch blickkontakt sehr
wichtig zu versuchen auszustrahlen dass ich dem
anderen so vorurteilsfrei und unvoreingenommen
wie möglich zu höre einfach dem anderen das
gefühl zu geben dass er die möglich dass sie
die möglichkeit hat was ich von mensch zu
mensch mit mir zu unterhalten nicht in eine
schublade gesteckt zu werden sondern einfach
mensch sein zu können das ist für mich also da
da geht es mir eigentlich darum und das also in
meiner erfahrung ich mache meinen beruf seit 21
jahren ist das auch also funktioniert das dann
auch meistens aber eben sie deuten es quasi an
es gibt immer die möglichkeit des scheiterns jetzt
frage ich mich sie beide und es hier haben lange
zeit seelsorge gemacht christliche seelsorge
sind inzwischen eben quasi nur noch akademisch
tätig und sie haben es schon angedeutet sind sehr
lange schon humanistische beraterin wie kommt man
denn zu einer solchen tätigkeit weswegen haben
sie zu tun begonnen was sie tun oder eben taten
bei mir war es so dass ich nach meinem studium
wo die letzten jahre rechts mit hindernissen
verlaufen und das ist jetzt ein psychologischer
technologie studiert in deutschland habe dann
zwei jahre vor ende meines studiums meinen mann
kennengelernt der berge ist und bin schwanger
geworden also das ist ganz viel gleichzeitig
passiert und dann war ich sehr froh mein studium
dann doch zu einem guten ende gelangt ist und
recht kurz danach habe ich bei der organisation
angefangen wo ich jetzt seit 21 jahren arbeite
und was hat mich daran angesprochen dass es um
wirklich die existenziellen fragen geht also
es geht um die ja die großen sinnfragen die
menschen beschäftigen nicht tagein tagaus bei
den meisten menschen ist so dass die durchs leben
gehen solange alles gut geht aber es gibt eben
dann im leben momente wo gewissen umbruch gibt
zwar plötzlich das ein oder andere verloren geht
wo menschen sich dann wohl anfangen zu fragen was
ist jetzt für mich eigentlich noch sinnvoll und
das hat mich enorm angesprochen als psychologin
und vor allem auch als mensch und da ich dann
eben die chance bekommen habe in der organisation
zu arbeiten der mensch jetzt heißt unsere
organisation und der inhalt unserer arbeit wir
sind eigentlich eine art humanistische pfarrer in
gewisser hinsicht wegbegleiter durch das leben von
beginn zu ende von der geburt bis zum tod das hat
mich das hat mich fasziniert ihn wirklich so ja
von mensch zu mensch mit den wesentlichen dingen
des lebens zu befassen darüber reden wir gerne
danach noch frau not wie kam es zu ihrer tätigkeit
sie eine vielzahl von faktoren die dazu geführt
haben und ich behaupte gar nicht dass ich den
größten teil überhaupt kenne sich mit eine rolle
gespielt haben biographische erlebnisse eigene
krisen schon in jugendjahren die die erfahrung
einfach nicht mehr weiter zu können absolut
verzweifelt zu sein und in solche situationen
menschen zu begegnen die einem helfen und die das
auf eine solche art und weise tun dass es wirklich
hilfreich war das heißt dass es mehr geholfen
hat sukzessive aus krisen herauszukommen gestärkt
herauszukommen und ich denke diese erfahrung
das hat mich sehr geprägt und hat mich dann auch
aufmerksam werden lassen ja wir haben die das
gemacht was war das denn genau was mitgeholfen
hat in situationen wo ich dachte da gibt es
überhaupt kein entrinnen mehr und dass ich denke
das was sich enorm wichtig neben vielen anderen
familiären konstellationen brüche kann ich bin
den usa geboren bin und in die schweiz gekommen
solche brüche also eine vielzahl von erfahrungen
die sich eine besondere sensibilität geweckt haben
für diese fragen und das interessante sie wissen
auch aus der psychotherapie forschung ein großteil
psychotherapeutische ansätze sind ja von sega von
psychologen psychotherapeuten entwickelt wurden
aufgrund auf der basis ihre eigenen erfahrungen
und ich denke dasselbe gilt auch in unserem beruf
und auch jetzt für die seelsorge und mich hat
dann natürlich auch interessiert die theoretische
reflexion dessen was wir machen ist weiß man aus
der forschung sind sie eben auch seit 2000 zwölf
professoren eben für seelsorge und residieren auch
den weiterbildungslehrgang spilacek er ja was ich
ganz interessant fand an diesem begriff und in der
recherchen vorgesprächen das den leuten eigentlich
gar nicht so klar ist was bild her ist und auch je
nachdem von wem an allen text liest ist da quasi
eine andere definition da frage ich mich wissen
die experten denn nicht was sie tun es ist so
wie sonst in der schweizerischen ärztezeitung
erste zeitung wurde vor ein paar jahren erschien
ein artikel und da stand es werden jetzt schon
lehrstühle eingerichtet für jetzt sogar noch
nicht mal weiß was es genau aber so wird er sagt
ja und deshalb auch an es existiert eine vielzahl
unterschiedlicher konzepte von spot repair genau
auch wie von seelsorge auch eine psychotherapie
und sie widersprechen sich zum teil aber was ist
es denn genau und sie sprechen etwas wichtiges
an was ist der unterschied zwischen spiritual
care und seelsorger so wandten betreibt mannsbild
verkehr und wann betreibt man dann seelsorge also
das sind jetzt irgendwie 45 fragen in einem ganz
kurz es gibt im moment gibt es zwei wenn ich jetzt
die pole nehme die eine seite die extreme sagt
also seelsorge ist eigentlich nichts anderes als
eine spezialisierte form von swatch ok da ist aus
der kasse joker ist der oberbegriff und seelsorge
ist das auch etwas religiöses konfessionell
gebunden sicher irgendwo institutionell gebunden
ist und auf der gegenseite sind diejenigen die
sagen ja also was soll dieses bildschirm das ist
doch eigentlich das was wir sehen sogar eigentlich
schon seit eh und je machen ja also das sind zumal
in dieser bandbreite finden sie also quasi fast
alles gar nicht unterschreiben so von dort ist
die die biologen und medizinern habt ihr ein buch
geschrieben hat darin auch aufgelistet ich weiß
wie viele unterschiedlichen verstehens weisen
im moment an zu finden sind von spox wenn sie
mich jetzt fragen wann macht jemanden sehe so
gewannen macht jemand türke es ist schwer zu
sagen am schluss würde ich sagen es sind fließende
übergänge es kommt darauf wiederum an was versteht
jemand darunter und am schluss bestimmt es dann
auch die person die das aufsuchen aber dann wenn
ich die frau isabel not frage was ist für sie
das bild verkehr dann wenn sie mich einfach so
wenn ich das einfach auf den park begriffe bringen
sie wollen von mir jetzt nicht mich wenn sie jetzt
nicht ich fühle mich einfach wirklich dazu sagen
es gibt diese ganze bankeinlagen wenn sie mich
persönlich fragen sage ich ihm es ist der von
der ich bin ursprünglich auch historie kriegen
mich interessieren natürlich die geschichtlichen
entwicklungen hat sich aus der hospizbewegung den
60er jahren des letzten jahrhunderts entwickelt
insbesondere aus der palliativpflege von dem er
ist es primär ein medizinisches setting aus
dem brk kam natürlich insbesondere auch aus
dem palliativ care gedanken es füge hier auch
sogleich an es war auch ein kritisches konzept
gegenüber eine medizin die biologistische
menschenbild pflegt den körper fixiert war
und man also es ist alles anders die versucht
hatten den griechen ihren turnieren die gesucht
hat wird die die verschiedenen bedürfnisse von
menschen in den blick zu dem unter anderem eben
auch spirituelle bedürfnisse was vergessen geht
sie sitzt wenn sie auch noch mal nicht frage dass
das auch häufiger auch sehr stark christlich
geprägt ist schon der begriff es wird so getan
als wäre das etwas jenseits des christlichen
ich meine schon notbetrieb spiritualität ist
ja sowas von christlich konnotiert und geprägt
dass das spannende daran eben an dem begriff
der spiritualität da würd mich dann auch ihre
meinung interessieren ist dass er eben in den
letzten jahren unglaublich eineinhalb quasi um ihn
geworden ist man sieht auch im wissenschaftlichen
publikationen wie der seit den letzten etwa
20 jahren wirklich fahrt aufgenommen haben
wir haben hier auch eine grafik mitgenommen
wo man das sieht es steigt seit 2012 würde
ich sagen in etwa bis jetzt heute das natürlich
die die grafik noch nicht fertig aber man sieht
steigt kontinuierlich an deswegen wurde denn
die spiritualität so wichtig ich kann natürlich
da auch nur vermutungen dazu anstellen ich denke
ist es ein basis bedürfnis des menschen jedweder
religiöser oder weltanschaulicher überzeugungen um
sich im sinn zu finden ihnen sind zu erfüllen und
ich denke unabhängig von der eigenen werte
überzeugung und so weiter ist es so dass
die fertig suche nach sind das ist dass es den
menschen eigen und das ist humanisten haben ja
den ruf dass sie sehr rational sind und alles
erklären können wollen ich persönlich ich bin
selber humanisten und humanistische beraterin ich
finde das auch interessant um alles zu untersuchen
ich untersuche auch gerne selbst und akzeptieren
nicht irgendwelche festen überzeugung die jemand
anders mir an reichen sie sind nicht dogmatisch
ich bin nicht dogmatisch aber das ist für mich
gerade weil ich von meiner praxis arbeit heraus
es ist für mich nicht wichtig alles erklären zu
können es ist einfach auch wichtig dass ich mich
als mensch berühren lassen kann dass ich mich
das mich dinge erschüttern das also dass und das
einfach was ist für mich spiritualität es ist für
mich eine fast transzendente erfahrung die meines
erachtens auch möglich ist wenn man selber nicht
an einen gott glaubt es ist und woran also wo
findet dann diese spirituelle erfahrung statt
unter anderem sehr intensiven kontakt von mensch
zu mensch wenn man den menschen begegnen das ist
gerade denke ich in unserer arbeit bei uns beiden
soll dabei jedweder spiritual care oder seelsorger
also das sind verschiedenen namen aber worum geht
es eigentlich in unserer arbeit den menschen nahe
sein in sehr schwierig momenten seines lebens
und wegbegleiter sein also gefühle von ohnmacht
und machtlosigkeit aushalten und zusammen gucken
was wo liegt die kraft des anderen um mit diesen
schwierigkeiten doch umzugehen und stand zu
halten also sagt jetzt dann auch in gewisser
hinsicht um resilienz widerstandskraft kommt
er also spiritualität was ist das das es so
dieser diese fast transzendenten moment wo
man dem anderen so nahe ist und in seiner
verletzbarkeit verwundbarkeit und in dem was
ihm oder ihr wirklich wichtig ist dann sagen
sie also es ist gewissermaßen eine menschliche
konstante die unabhängig davon ob jemand irgendwie
einen metaphysischen bezug hat oder nicht beim
menschen vorkommt also sie quasi lösen das jetzt
klar auch von der religion da interessiert mich
natürlich jetzt ihre meinung deswegen auch das
so wichtig wurde jetzt wie man gesehen hat das
ist ja wirklich erstaunlich ja das hat das hat
natürlich auch hier wieder sehr unterschiedliche
gründe ganz sicher ist in einer multireligiösen
weltanschaulich pluralen welt ist es einfacher zu
sagen ich bin spirituell also ich bin religiös und
es gibt eine vielzahl von untersuchungen die auch
zeigen was menschen mit diesem begriff notieren
was sie eigentlich damit mein und da kommen
dann bei spiritualität kommen begriffe wie natur
geist sind werden bei religion kommen dogma kirche
gottesdienst in institution und das führt dann ein
bisschen dazu dass religion für alles herhalten
muss für das verfasste institutionalisierte und
spiritualität ist quasi dann das gute das was mit
freiheit verbunden ist und das ist der grund wieso
wir jetzt dieses bild ok ausbildung aufgegleist
haben wir wie gesagt hat im moment wir haben ja
eigentlich in einer langen langen geschichte der
theologischen auseinandersetzung herausgefunden
dass religion stets ambivalent ist es gibt keine
religion an sich die gut wert oder die schlechte
und dasselbe gilt für die spiele es gibt keine
spiritualität und sich wir haben auch da dieselben
phänomen es gibt spiritualität formen die menschen
krank machen können die sie in die abhängigkeit
führen können genauso wie beim ganzen thema
religion deshalb ist es so wichtig jetzt auch
mit religions- psychologischer perspektive diese
begriffe und insbesondere dann die bestimmten
aus formen wie wird die spiritualität konkret
gelebt wie wird religiosität gelebt auch da es
ist ja eine so enorme spannweite innerhalb der
fan religionen oder wenn jemand muslimisch ist
heißt das noch lange nicht dass sie alle
dasselbe praktizieren oder da gibt es eine
solche diversität wie christentum ja sowieso
man muss vielleicht anmerken sie sind ja auch
noch religion psychologin nebst theologin also
haben sie ganz ihr themenfeld 2000 sie arbeiten
eben seit jahren in belgien als humanistische
beraterin sie bieten das heißt letztlich bieten
religionsfreie gespräche an auf welche werte
berufen sie sich denn da konkret ich persönlich
in meiner haltung den anderen gegenüber als
mensch ich berufe mich auf die humanistischen
werte und was ist darin für mich zentral das ist
dass der mensch selbst verantwortlich ist als er
tapfer und träger seine eigenen werte es gibt im
prinzip keine übergeordnete instanz die mir sagt
was objekt eine objektive in anführungszeichen
gut oder schlecht ist und es ist sehr wichtig
die dinge immer wieder erneut in frage zu
stellen also die die frau das prinzip der
freien untersuchungen also teils sachverhalte in
frage zu stellen meine haltung den dingen der welt
anderen gegenüber in frage zu stellen also das
ist ich meine grundwerte sind humanistisch wobei
es so ist das im prinzip bei mir alle menschen
willkommen sind und ich erlebe dass die meisten
die den weg zu mir finden beziehungsweise dann
die ich dann besuche im krankenhaus im altersheim
eine psychiatrie das sind menschen die die meisten
sind zumindest nicht kirchlich nicht gläubig da
bin ich sehr vorsichtig weil ich finde ich stehe
übrigens persönlich als romanistin ich stehe
gläubigen menschen nicht ablehnend gegenüber ich
finde das fürchterlich arrogant ich finde es ist
wichtig dass es einfach alles gleichwertig
nebeneinander bestehen darf für mich die
humanistischen werte im prinzip sind interessen
main es ist mein ausgangspunkt und ich begegne
dem anderen von mensch zu mensch und es passiert
durchaus auch das auch religiöse zum teil gläubige
menschen sich an mich wenden vor allem dann wenn
es um themen geht wo sie davon ausgehen dass sie
sich in kirchlichen kreisen oder religiösen damit
einem religiösen gesprächspartner womöglich in der
tabus fähre befinden wie zb eben wie gehe ich um
mit umgewöhnen unerwünschte schwangerschaft wie
gehe ich um mit dem wunsch nach sterbehilfe uns
so weiter also das sind das sind themen wo ich
merke dass in der wahrnehmung dass andere das ich
als humanistische beraterin dass sie das gefühl
haben das was er auch seine annahme natürlich es
gibt auch fantastische kirchliche oder christliche
seelsorge die genauso offen und vorurteilsfrei
zu hören können die ich das kann aber in der
wahrnehmung der menschen die sich an mich wenden
ist es das spielt das oft eine rolle sie denken
aber mit einer humanistischen beraterin mit der
sonne sicher stern sie sprechen jetzt das schon
ein bisschen an was mich natürlich interessiert
und auch die zuschauer interessiert für menschen
in ihrer rolle gibt es geschichten die sie ganz
besonders bewegt haben die sie teilen dürfen
es gibt eine fülle an begegnungen und und menschen
die mich die mich beschäftigt haben und die mir
ab und zu wieder in den sinn kommen jetzt auch
wenn ich jetzt seit mehreren jahren wirklich
in der ausbildung tätig bin es gibt personen
die mir noch nach jahren ich sage jetzt mal
vielleicht drei vier mal pro jahr anrufen und
da geht es schlecht und nur darum eine kurze
kontaktaufnahme die wollen nicht dass ich ihnen
einen termin anbieten oder mit ihnen zum kaffee
episoden es reicht einfach schnell miteinander
im kontakt stehen und das ist das was mich so
fasziniert an diese niederschwellig kite der
seelsorge dass sie auch da ist für menschen
die aus einer psychotherapeutischen perspektive
chancenlos sind aufgegeben wurde erst recht als
eine psychiatrischen perspektive die die nicht
die können sich mehr da wenn sie nicht mehr
an sich arbeiten wollen oder nicht können das
ist nicht die voraussetzung 7 dürfen genau so
bleiben wie sie sind und es genügt in diese kurze
kontaktaufnahme mehr wäre für sie wahrscheinlich
gar nicht auszuhalten und das ist das schöne und
der seelsorge dass sie das geben kann ich stimme
zu dass für mich und das sehr treffend formuliert
und sehr interessant dass es ja und das ist auch
was ich zu erklären versuchte ein aspekt der
spiritualität ist für mich ebenso dieses intense
momente das kontakt dass ich ein mensch zu mensch
und das braucht tatsächlich nicht lange zu dauern
in meinem empfinden nach ist das was ich vor
allem bieten kann was ich so wertvoll finde
und wo ich auch das feedback bekommen von dem
anderen oder der anderen dass das wertvoll ist
dass der andere bei mir mensch sein darf dass es
nicht darum geht zu diagnostizieren was ist ein
krankheitsbild das ist eine störung sondern dass
der andere einfach gefühl haben kann hier darf ich
einfach sein der ich bin hier darf ich ganz mensch
sein hier gilt mein menschsein im vordergrund und
das ist auch so dass in unserer arbeit geht es
eigentlich nicht so sehr um das erreichen von
bestimmten zielen innerhalb eines bestimmten
zeitraums natürlich darf was erreicht werden
und sehen wir menschen unglaublich evaluieren
oft sehen dass die menschen wachsen und sich
weiterentwickeln und stärker werden aber es
ist bei uns keine prämisse dass das passieren
muss bei uns geht es eigentlich um akzeptanz es
geht darum dass es ja oft schwierige situationen
das dass es einfach das design dürfen was es in
erster linie dass sie nicht gelöst werden müssen
dass es dass der andere nicht das gefühl hat ich
bin abnormal weil ich damit nicht nicht so gut
umgehen kann der andere darf darf sich darf darf
damit schwierigkeiten haben der andere darf sein
wie er ist in dem moment und das ist ja 70 mir bei
sojasoße das finde ich dass das finde ich dass das
wertvolle der mensch als ganzes ohne dass ich ihn
beurteilen ich wollte eben genau darauf ansprechen
weil die frauen und not hat ja sie haben das zwar
nicht ganz ausgeführt aber wie mir scheint es ist
doch so dass das bild wirkt er genauso wie die
palliativmedizin sich quasi auf eine auf diese
vier ebenen des menschen beziehen ebene es ist
ja er ist eben nicht nur körper oder nicht nur
geist oder oder psyche sondern eben über das ist
etwas über das was ihnen quasi das seelische oder
spirituelle quasi mit einbezieht und da frage
ich mich inwiefern haben auch sie als humanist
in ein politisches menschenbild oder eben fehlt
da etwas das ist quasi eine kritische rückfrage
in bezug auf den holistischen begriff des menschen
es ist natürlich in atheistischen kreisen großer
diskussionspunkt die seele gibt es sie oder gibt
es nichts die hardcore atheisten am die neigung
zu sagen seele ist ein christlich besetzter
begriff ich persönlich sehe den begriff der
seele er in so definition die psyche und in der
hinsicht habe ich damit kein problem also ist
für mich der mensch etwas was jeder mensch ist
ein ganzes aus körper seele geist und die partie
die verschiedenen teile auch nicht voneinander
trennen wollen sondern das ist einfach dass es
eine wechselwirkung zwischen all den teilen also
es ist ich persönlich habe kein problem mit dem
begriff der sehen aber finde es natürlich auch
wichtig dass deutlich ist dass das noch aus der
seele ein weiterer begriff ist als eben nur so wie
es in den kirchlichen kreisen definiert wird das
werden wir jetzt ein bisschen zu eng kirchliche
das weiß ich nicht genau weiß welche sie damit
genau meinen wichtigkeit mit wenn sie sagen körper
geist seele ich meine es gibt eine solche vielzahl
unterschiedlicher konzepte und auch das was sie
hier gebracht haben hat natürlich einen klaren
traditionsstrecke wir haben ja insbesondere zwei
traditionsstrecke in der ganzen seelen diskussion
ein griechisch antiken und den auf denen sie
jedem die seelsorge beruf ist dieser wert legt
auf dieses wurzel und das ist halt schon die
hebräische anthropologie es gibt kein direktes
adäquaten begriff im hebräischen dafür aber in
der günter wurde ja der begriff nachteil das
ist die seele der jugend der schlund die kehle
der atem der rachen also diese teil hier die
empfänglichkeit des menschen da wo wir aufnehmen
wo wir luft aufnehmen das wird dann quasi zum
mensch selbst zum leben selbst und das unter der
mensch ist die seele qual mensch ist das ist in
seiner ganzen empfänglichkeit und das wurde dann
übersetzt mit psyche in der seb günther und dann
halt mit seele und es hat die griechische
ausgabe muss man vielleicht hat sie die
griechische ausgabe der das des alten testaments
und diese begriffe nash umfasst also den menschen
als ganzes und die seelsorge bezieht sich zurück
auf dieses menschenbild dieses wirklich umfassende
der menschen seine vitalität der punkt ist dass
bei diesem hebräischen denken es keine tradition
vorstellbar da irgendwie körper zu trennen von
vernunft und von sales das sind keine qualität
high dort das gehört zusammen der mensch ist nach
der mensch ist zähle er hat keine seele also er
ist ist und dass deshalb ist diese begriffe uns
ich bin ihm sehr dankbar so wie sie beschrieben
haben das ist also das darf also und das fast
erleuchtend videos kann man da wirklich kann
mich damit für erfolg kommen ist ja da dass wir
uns dafür hab ich noch kurz zurück war das nicht
doch wunderbar sie sagen religionslos religions-
lose gespräch habe ich das richtig ja ich glaube
das waren begriffen dass sie genauer gesagt haben
wenig oder große gleiche es ist natürlich da ich
ja mich auf die humanistischen werte beziehen die
ja zu einem ganz großen teil wenn man guckt einen
verschiedenen weltanschauungen und religionen
um welche werte geht es eigentlich ich lehne
mich zurück ich war zufällig mal im neanderthal
museum im neandertal in deutschland das gibt es
also wirklich das neandertal das ein ganz tolles
museum und das geht in der spirale in dem gang
nach oben und da entlang sind so die verschiedenen
aus den verschiedensten kulturen und religionen
und weltanschauungen sind so die zentralen
werte zusammengefasst und dass die stehen
so gleichberechtigt nebeneinander und da fällt
einerseits schön auf wo so gewisse spezifische
unterschiede sind aber was mindestens genauso
auffällt ist dass es eine ganz große gemeinsame
basis gibt und die humanistischen werte was da
natürlich wo daten die die schwerpunkt dass sie
natürlich in den verschiedenen weltanschauungen
etwas anders und was er noch immer beim humanismus
stark im vordergrund steht ist autonomie und
selbstbestimmung natürlich immer in verbundenheit
mit dem anderen menschen meine autonomie oder
freiheit geht genauso weiter bis 7 die freiheit
das anderen in bedrängnis genau aber jedenfalls
die selbstbestimmung ist sehr sehr wichtig immer
also in meiner tätigkeit oder in also in meinen
humanistischen werte hintergrund es ist allerdings
natürlich so ich beziehe mich nicht auf einen
gott also religionslos und der begriff swerts
nicht einer der mir direkt ein viele wenn mich
jemand fragt was machst du eigentlich will ich
nicht sagen ich mache religions- lose gespräche
aber ich würde möglicherweise ich würde denke
ich so umschreiben ich bin wegbegleiterin durchs
leben vom anfang bis zum ende von der geburt bis
zum tod ich bin da in den wichtigen momenten
des lebens die für den anderen wirklich die
den anderen berühren und muss entweder was zu
feiern gibt zwar in berge machen wir auch feiern
zur wichtigen lebensmomente also muss man da noch
kurz einführen in belgien ist es ja noch speziell
in bezug auf die religion situation also es ist
zwar ein katholisches land und stark katholisch
geprägt dabei soweit ich weiß sind die menschen
die eben quasi religions- ungebunden sind nicht
eben der kirche angehören fast die hälfte der
gesellschaft machen die aus und insofern dass
man ein bisschen die relation hat das ist das gut
dass sie das tatsächlich noch hinzufügen das ist
so ja denn das ist spiegelt sich auch wider
in der gesetzgebung in der tatsache dass es
meine art der tätigkeit seit über 30 jahren gibt
mittlerweile es ist genau das sei das einfach
eben das hat sich so in berlin entwickelt und
das hat eben einen rahmen geschaffen innerhalb
dessen humanistische beratung möglich ist und
ich persönlich bin sehr dankbar für nicht nur
weil ich meinen beruf selber sehr gern macht
sondern weil ich einfach davon ausgehe ich habe
vorhin schon gesagt ich finde die verschiedensten
weltanschauungen sind gleichberechtigt und ich
finde das sehr wichtig dass man miteinander
ins gespräch kommt ich habe auch keinerlei
feindbilder ich mein hintergrund ist selbst meine
eltern sind evangelisch nicht verteilt aber ich
finde ich finde das einfach wichtig deutlich zu
machen wie ich selber im leben stehe ich anderen
weltanschauungen und religionen gegenüber steht
dass es für mich keine anti haltung ist sondern
ein ja im nebeneinander bestehen einer fruchtbar
ergänzen spannenden dialog sich einsperren dialog
gegeben ich möchte gerne aber ich möchte gerne
hier etwas weiter fahren sie haben sofort selber
angesprochen die resilienz es ist ja so dass mit
krisensituationen das wissen sie besser als ich
nicht jeder mensch auf dieselbe weise umgeht eben
gewisse menschen zerbrechen daran und bei anderen
staunt man wie stark sie sind wir haben hier
ein beispiel von einer besonders starken person
diese frau hat mich sehr berührt eben in ihrer
widerstandsfähigkeit gegen die schicksalsschläge
eben was man resilienz nennt inwiefern
hat residenz auch in ihrer arbeit jeweils
reingespielt oder brasilien resilienz training
für patienten oder klienten beeindruckt einen
jahr zutiefst ich finde es ist ja wirklich möchte
man sagen ist ein wunder dass ein mensch wie acht
jahre damals diese diese enormen kräfte entwickelt
und wie sie da gesagt weit weit und dann gab es
kein halten mehr ich denke es geht darum in der
seelsorge in speed ok in gesprächen zu schauen
wo können menschen solche ressourcen aktivieren
und wo können sie etwas so aktivieren dass sie
in die kraft gibt jetzt weiter zu fahren also
das ist absolut grundlegend und ich denke der
haut punkt ist dass wir sehen das alles wirklich
auf die persönliche einschätzung darauf ankommt
hätte diese person die einschätzung gehabt mein
leben ist jetzt zu ende und so kann kein mensch
leben dann wäre mit aller wahrscheinlichkeit
dass bedeutend schwieriger gewesen als mit
dieser einstellung ich habe den traum ich will
da wieder ein ich will wieder spielen ich will
mich ins leben werfen als eigentlich umso
spezieller als so junges kind wo man so viel
unterwegs ist und dann explizit die beine fehlen
sorgen machen sie so was wie resilienz training
nicht gezählt also ist es nicht so dass ich den
gegenwert zu mir kommen sagt wir machen jetzt
resilienz training aber das ist das schon also
was passiert in den gesprächen hat damit zu tun
ich versuche zu explorieren wo die inneren kräfte
das analoge gegen genauso ich habe als berater und
ich denke kein guter seelsorger des humanismus
oder nicht wir haben keine standard antworten
zu beten macht s oder das dann wird schon gut
wir untersuchen gemeinsam mit dem anderen wo
die kräfte liegen wird und was sie sagen die
einschätzung ist das a und o ich stimme dem zu
und was wir oft wo wir helfen können ist dass
wir die situation versuchen aus einem anderen
blickwinkel zu belangen also dass wir dem anderen
nahe genug sind dass das gefühl hat da ist eine
vertrauensperson an meiner seite dem die mich
also die die bäume ist dies das haben wir die
situation aushält und dass ich trotzdem weit
genug weg bin um auch einen anderen blickwinkel
ein emotionen und daneben dem anderen auch ja
zu helfen irgendwie die eigene einschätzung der
situation zu ändern und die eigenen kräfte zu
entdecken als vieler menschen ich fand die frau
auch unglaublich beeindruckend dabei ist es ja
auch so speziell man sieht wirklich empfehlen
wie stark sie erleben leben kann sie ja sogar
zwei kinder aber es ist erschreckend innerhalb
von irgendwie 30 jahre später oder so innerhalb
von einer woche sterben die zwei engsten personen
von ihr und dann plötzlich spricht sie über ihre
gefühle und da merkt man was was in ihr vorgeht
sie spricht er hier sogar von suizidgedanken ich
fand das gewissermaßen erstaunlich dass diese frau
die zuvor so stark war und etwas durchlebt hat
dass viele sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen können
dann durch diese schicksalsschläge so aus der bahn
geworfen wird dahinter steht die vorstellung wir
sein wie konstant wir sind wir sind wie sie
nicht stabil gewesen je nach situation je
nach lebensphase je nach ganz vielen verschiedenen
aspekten können wir auch unterschiedlich reagieren
von daher finde ich es sehr plausibel dass
eine person unterschiedlich stark stark in
anführungszeichen auch das ist eine enorme stärke
dass diese gefühle kommen können das auch gefühle
wie suizidalität dass es auch bestandteil ist eine
ganz vehementen reaktion auf einen solchen norden
schicksal einer akuten krise quasi eine gesunde
reaktion sagen sie fast schon völlig im bereich
des menschlich normale und an führung ist nicht
selbstverständlich also das ist überhaupt kein das
kann man nicht bewerten als irgendwie die person
sei jetzt da nicht stark nein es zeichnet ja auch
menschen aus dass sie das durch leben können die
frage ist wie sieht das aus nach ein paar monaten
das ist ja dann die entscheidende frage dass als
reaktion ist das sehr verständlich ich möchte
einen schritt weiter gehen oder vielleicht
das quasi auch mit dem vorhergehenden noch
verbinden in bezug auf das verhältnis jetzt
auch von humanistischer beratung und switche
der seelsorge weil man könnte eben auch sagen
es gibt ja offenkundig sie haben dasselbe zur
forschung angesprochenen auf den bezug auf die
spiritualität einen wandeln bezug eben auf die
relevanz von institutionelle institutionalisierter
religion was man ihnen auch in belgien sehr gut
zieht und da könnte man ja fragen ist dann die
humanistische beratung eben nicht so was wie das
wirkliche zukunftsmodell von seelsorge ja da bin
also ich bin zwar um eine schöne berater ich mache
meinen beruf sehr gern und ich hoffe auch dass
er bis in die weitere zukunft bestehen bleibt
aber ich fände es eigentlich immer arroganz wenn
irgend eine bestimmte ausrichtung der seelsorge
ob sie jetzt religiös oder humanistisch ist für
sich beanspruchen würde ich bin das einzig wahre
genau aber die frage ist ja würde es vielleicht
nicht als antwort aus der gesellschaft heraus
kommen das ist natürlich auch eine spannende
frage für die religions- psychologie also ich
kenne die humanistische beratung insbesondere
aus dem us amerikanischen kontext und mädchen
auch dort engagiert ist das richtig ich habe ich
wollte im rahmen von forschungsprojekten torten
tja und was mir dort ausgezeichnet gefällt ist ja
die zusammenarbeit und wenn wir ja immer wieder
versuchen müssen von den personen auszudenken
die seelsorge oder beratung suchen das sind
ja dass die müssen wir uns die kriterien geben
dann finde ich von diesen personen aus gesehen
ist es doch wunderbar gibt es ein vielfältiges
angebot das heißt ich darf nicht von mir aus
denken und sagen ein es gibt nur die gesetzliche
oder sorgen von von diesen personen ausgedacht ist
je nach situation kann eine andere person mit
einem anderen hintergrund genau diese person
das richtige gehen und unsere aufgabe ist zu
schauen dass die vielfalt möglichst gerader
und insgesamt in einer solchen multireligiösen
nochmals weltanschaulich pluralen gesellschaft
genau unter bringen sie mich zum nächsten punkte
nämlich in der schweiz und sie waren da quasi auch
zu besuch gibt es ja eben auch die freidenker und
der präsident der freidenker andreas korea co hat
ja so was wie die wohl sorge quasi gefordert
was eben staatlich finanziert wie er jetzt als
kompliment zu religiös geprägten seelsorge und man
muss ja schon wissen in der schweiz in mindestens
ein nicht mindestens sondern sind genau etwa
ein viertel der bevölkerung konfessionslos das
heißt natürlich nicht dass die religionslos sind
aber zumindest sind sie konfessionslos heißt das
dass ihre seelsorger des bildschirm kleben für die
atheisten nicht genügt der gedankengang werden wir
jetzt etwas zu schnell weil weil die saison hat
ja den anspruch dass sie ist ja so in die welt
getreten sage ich mal mit dem anspruch dass sie
für alle da sein soll und sie hatte auch explizit
konzept entwickelt die eben nicht einfach nur
spezifisch für die eigenen kirchenmitglieder
sind sollten wirklich die note oder otto oder die
bedürfnisse aller anspricht jetzt was freidenker
anbelangt wir stehen ja auch in gesprächen das
alles wunderbar ich glaube nicht dass ein viertel
der schweizer bevölkerung jetzt freidenker sind
im sinne wie es frei denkt geht selber verstehen
da bin ich überzeugt dass das nicht so ist der
punkt wäre für mich wie sieht die ausbildung
nicht ich würde einfach nicht unterschätzen dass
das menschen sind diesen einer verletzlichen
situation und sie bringen beratungs personen sehen
sollten dann sehr viel vertrauen entgegen und ich
möchte und ich denke dass auch unsere aufgabe dass
wir schauen alles getan wird dass die personen die
dann staatlicherseits dem zugang erhalten zu
diesen person wirklich vertrauenswürdig sind
und das heißt gut ausgebildet seriös ausgebildet
und wirklich wissen was sie da tun und da gehören
gerade im existenziellen bereich gehört hat
schon ziemlich viel dazu vorsichtig umzugehen
in der weil sie und weil sie befürchten dass es
da auch missbräuche eben geben kann so ist es ja
aber ich möchte da trotzdem ganz kurz noch drauf
eingehen oder das erwidern weil sie sagen sie ist
die seelsorge ist zwar für alle das problem ist
nur wenn diese alle in teilen von diesen tagen
ihr aber die wollen dieses organ nicht in dieser
form das ist ja eigentlich letztlich das was die
freidenker sagen schön und gut seid ihr für alle
aber wir wollen nicht zu diesen allen gehören
und das unterstützen sie ja dass es dieses
gesprächsangebot und da möchte ich euch doch
zurückkommen auf das was sie vorher gesagt haben
was ich sehr schön formuliert haben es ist die
vielfalt die wichtig ist es eben gleichberechtigt
verschiedene angebote nebeneinander gehen weil
ich denke sie gehen somit mit den menschen um
das im prinzip dass es für alle da sein kann
genauso gilt das auch für mich ich bin ja also
das ist ja vorher auch schon ausgeführt habe
ich bin nicht nur für die nichtreligiösen oder
für die nicht konfessionell gebunden da sondern
für alle im prinzip aber so das haben sie sehr
schön formuliert eigentlich ist das wichtigste
dass wir vom anderen ausdenken und die bedürfnisse
es gibt also wie viel prozent das sind dann möchte
ich mich überhaupt nicht darauf festlegen ob das
jetzt ein viertel der bevölkerung des weniger oder
mehr es gibt jedenfalls doch beträchtlich viele
menschen die wohl das bedürfnis haben dass sie
selber entscheiden können wenn ich mich jetzt an
so einen seelsorger so ein oder der humoristische
beratung es ist einfach ich denke es wäre eine
enorme bereicherung ein enormer reichtum wenn
es eben diese vans verschiedenen der derjenige der
in existenzieller not ist die möglichkeit hat sich
selbst entscheiden an wen er oder sie sich wenden
kann das wäre wichtig und ich denke das ist vor
allem den freidenkern auch ein anliegen nicht so
sehr um sich selbst zu profilieren hoher wir sind
toll und wir machen das jetzt sondern einfach so
ich denke im moment sehen sie ihre aufgabe darin
dafür zu sorgen dass es dass es in der zukunft
diese möglichkeit gibt wohl sorge sie haben den
begriff hantiert das war auf der suche nach einem
nach einem namen war das so einer der ersten fälle
ich habe mich gestern noch mit zwei menschen von
den freidenkern unterhalten und sie haben gesagt
für uns wäre es schön wenn du das auch benennen
könnte ist als humanistische gesprächsangeboten
damit kann ich mich sehr gut identifizieren und
im endeffekt es ist natürlich wichtig dass das
das ganze einen namen erhält oder später aber das
allerwichtigste ist denke ich dass der bevölkerung
vor allem deutlich wird was beinhalten kann und
dann ja der name ist nicht unwichtig aber es
ist nicht das wichtigste wichtigstes der inhalt
ganz gemäß wichtig zu sagen dass sie so ist ein
freiwilliges angebot das ist absolut zentral und
studien zeigen dass das die seelsorge sehr beliebt
ist und sehr gut ankommt in den verschiedenen
institutionen das uns sehr wichtig so ist es
in ergänzung zu anderen berufssparten das ist so
also ich sehe mich auch nicht als die also würde
ich sagen dass das ein psychologe macht oder
ein sozialarbeiter oder einen arzt oder also
gerade berufssparten haben ihren eigenen wert das
schöne ist eigentlich das liegt in der ergänzung
generell ich möchte der einhalten weil sie haben
mir im vorgespräch auch gesagt dass für sie in der
seelsorge immer etwas drittes mitbürger so sind
sie und die gesprächs person und es wirkt etwas
drittes mit und ich habe mich dann gefragt wie
stark verbreitet sind tatsächlich so klassisch
materialistische sichtweisen also wo es quasi
nur die körperliche ebene gibt nichts was quasi
den menschen selber als materie übersteigt bei
sterbenden das finde ich wirklich sehr interessant
auch in bezug jetzt auf diese auf diese forderung
der wohl sorge wie verbreitet ist dass ich denke
es werden interessante phase im leben benannt bei
sterbenden denke dass jemand der in seiner letzten
lebensphase ist noch mal sehr stark so die eigenen
werte sehr stark in den vordergrund genommen das
ist auch bei humanistisch orientiert menschen so
und das interessant ist dann eigentlich dass ich
da bin um noch mal zu gucken was ist dem oder der
anderen eigentlich wirklich wichtig und ich denke
da geht es in jedweder form der seelsorge drum
also es ist bei gläubigen menschen denke ich
werden auch noch mal die die eigenen glaubens
begriffe gegen schlicht gehalten ist also ich
denke die meisten gläubigen haben auch ihre
momente des zweifels ist wichtig ist einfach
dass man als seelsorger den raum und die zeit und
die möglichkeit bietet zusammen mit einem anderen
zu untersuchen was ist mir wichtig was bedeutet
mir was wohl ich das gibt mir kraft und ja also
bei humanistisch orientierten menschen sind es
eben im allgemeinen die dirty die humanistischen
werte also die zum teil überlappen mit so sich
überschneiden mit den werten den anderen welt
anschauen aber das ist also es ist ja so ist es
aber das ist für mich beantwortet die frage noch
nicht wie verbreitet jetzt diese eben ganz rein
materialistische sichtweise ist eben sie sagen das
spezifisch eben in diesem lebensabschnitt von bei
sterbenden und ich spreche das natürlich bewusst
da an weil man kennt das ja auch dass in diesen
situationen sie haben dasselbe erwähnt personen
noch mal ihre werte überdenken denn religiöse
personen haben sie mir auch noch betont im volk
spricht teilweise sogar speziell leiden weil
sie habe dann entweder mit dem glauben oder mit
gewissen dogmen die quasi weitergereicht werden
in der religion was sagen sie dazu würden sie
sagen wie verbreitet ist dass ich glaube jetzt
keine empirische studie irgendwie gerade parat
was was was das anbelangt aber es ist sicher
dass die die religiosität die spiritualität
die eine person während ihres lebens praktiziert
hat oder die auffassung deine person sicher dann
auch in der letzten phase ihres lebens prägen
seine und wenn ist das deshalb ist es ja auch
so wichtig auch in der theologie zu schauen
und auch in der beratung natürlich auch was
sind das lebens förderliche vorstellung sind das
lebenslängliche vorstellen sind das oder sind
das solche die menschen klein machen unabhängig
machen und das sind ja die die knackpunkte an
denen es dann zu arbeiten gibt gibt es da noch
ein bisschen spielraum der jetzt wichtig werden
könnte dieser letzten phase das sind so themen es
gibt ja auch studien die die genesung verbinden
mit der religiosität oder eben spiritualität
einer person also wo man sagt dass die person
die eben quasi diesen rückhalt hat eine bessere
oder schnellere genesung also hätte da gibt es
eine vielzahl an die zeigen dass personen die
frau tot sind die religiöse vorstellungen haben
aus parat haben die religiös spirituellen leben
dass die wir sprechen dann von der salutogenese
aus das ist gesundheitsfördernd das hilft bei dem
kolping mechanismen das heißt religion konnte man
kann besser damit um gewaltige ja weil man sehen
und orientierung verschiedene geschichten und
bilder und vorstellungswelten parat hat die einen
hilfreich sein können in der deutung der eigenen
situation also dass das ist glaube ich sehe nicht
ich glaube das ist sehr gut untersucht und auch
sehr spannend wobei eben und das möchte ich schon
sagen auch die andere seite es gibt natürlich eine
vielzahl von von vorstellungen die menschen
dann auch knechten können ja genau aber was
ich daran schon spannend finde ich möchte das
auch kritisch reflektiert wie sie arbeiten ja
aus diesen gründen auch mit mit medizinischen
fakultät zusammen also und deswegen ist das
bild verkehr sicher auch anerkannt im bereich der
medizin aber man könnte ja auch sagen das ist eine
pervertierung der spiritualität wenn sie eben
für diesen evaluieren beitrag der medizin quasi
ausgenutzt wird wir kennen diese bewegung in mein
volles bewegungen zb diverse große unternehmen
bieten ihren ihren mitarbeitern meditationskurs an
über mittag und danach sind sie weniger krank sie
arbeiten besser konzentrierter weniger fällt
fehler also man könnte es auch so sehen das
ist meine große kritik und der geschichte die
die ganze bezirke sowie palliativ care ist die
ursprünglich aus einem einem kritischen impetus
entstanden sie wollten die die medizin vielleicht
nicht gerade revolutionär aber fast und was
jetzt geschehen ist je mehr sich die medizin
die diese thematik angenommen hat desto mehr wie
die spiritualität medikalisierung also anstatt
dass es zu einer veränderung rückkopplungseffekte
in speziellen gekommen wäre sprechen wir umgekehrt
sich von special dieses bild fridman all diese
fachbegriffe die eigentlich also einen ganz
anderen kontext stammen werden nun in diesen
spiritualität zusammenhang eingefügt und und
dass sie uns schon in welche richtung das es
läuft und dass das gefällt mir nicht und da
bin ich wirklich sehr sehr kritisch ich möchte da
einfach ganz kurz zurück fragen die kritik an der
medizin ist jene dass der mensch quasi einfach
nur eindimensional gesehen wird und einfach auch
diese diese ökonomisierung und und das alles
immer wieder so rational erläutert werden also
das unverfügbare das was doch ja gerade wenn
menschen krank sind viel viel bedrängender und
viele offensichtliche da ist dass das das wird
versucht irgendwie rote zu drücken und portugal
seelsorge humanistische beratung das sind ja alles
versuche irgendwie dieses zu werden zu sagen doch
da gibt es der mensch ist letztlich doch auch
irgendwie ein geheimnis ich hoffe sie würden
also da gibt es auch ganz viele aspekte die können
wir nicht messen und evaluieren und so weiter und
dies die diese diese perspektiven müssen evivo
lebendig bleiben sonst werden wir menschen nicht
gerecht jetzt möchte ich da noch nachfragen wir
haben viel darüber gehört was die personen die
gesprächspartner von ihnen auch lernen aber was
lernen sie denn von von diesen leuten angelaufen
das entschuldigung nicht ins wort schlagen war
war es so dass also ich bin nach meinen beruf
gerne ich bin auch ein bescheidener mensch und
ich bin so dankbar für die vielen bereichen und
beeindruckende momente die ich in meiner arbeit
in der begegnung mit dem anderen als menschen
schon erleben durfte was ich was mich nach wie
vor enorm berührt ist wenn leute die wirklich
schwierigste sachen erleben wie die sich ihre
eigenen verletzlichkeit nähern und gerade darin
eigentlich oft die kraft finden und mit mit
diesen schwierigen situationen umzugehen und
die leute ich finde auch faszinierend mich darauf
einzulassen die wie die verschiedensten menschen
auf ganz verschiedene art und weise im leben
stehen und sich den dingen gegenüber verhalten
und sich auf den weg begeben untersuchen das ist
das ist faszinierend es ist unglaublich lehrreich
ich frage mich wenn menschen so viel mit solchen
personen die in totalen krisensituationen oder
in den sterbenden situationen sind begegnen
viel mit ihnen zu tun haben gespräche führen
wie sie beide hat man dann noch angst vor
dem tod sie kennen ja den schönen satz ich
habe nicht angst vor dem eigenen tod aber den
anderen und oder man ist wenn der eigene tod
es geht mir persönlich so auch vor operationen da
kann ich wunderbar eingehen und denken könnte ich
jetzt so gehen unter täglich doch aber angst
macht mit natürlich familiäres umfeld freunde
freundinnen mein vater ist das ganz ähnlich angst
vor dem eigenen tor habe ich eigentlich nicht
aber es ist ich hab selber auch schon in meiner
umgebung damit gibt miterlebte wie menschen die
mir sehr nahe standen gestorben sind das ist das
ist eine große herausforderung und ich denke was
mein eigenes leben betrifft angst vor dem sterben
das ist noch etwas anderes finde ich also vom tod
sein ich persönlich geht es nicht also ich weiß
nicht ob es nach dem tod noch was geben wird oder
nicht ich gehe in erster linie davon aus dass
es auch nicht so die große rolle spielt ob jetzt
mein persönliches leben weitergeht oder nicht also
man das denke ich davon aus dass ich sowieso auch
weiter lebe in dem was ich hinterlasse in der
erinnerung anderer menschen in tastbar uns und
immateriell das ist ja schon biblisch ja es ist
also das ist also ob ich jetzt selber aufstehen
also für mich spielt das spielt es keine rolle
aber es ist also davon meinem eigenen sterben
da wünsche ich mir natürlich schon dass das
nicht also janka sident prozess spricht ja
genau was ich kurz hinzufügen wollte zu dem was
sie fordern so sehr schön geschrieben haben also
meinem empfinden nach sehr schön geschrieben
haben dass verankert sein wo sie fragt und es
gibt ja diese vielen studien die deutlich machen
dass jemand der auf was bestimmtes zurückgreifen
kann in der also gerade beim sterben dass das
hilft oder dass es sich bei der genesung wenn
genesung noch möglich ist dem stimme ich
absolut zu ich denke es wichtig ist dass
verankert sein und auch da ist es natürlich so
dass meines erachtens in meinem empfinden nach
dass auch menschen die nicht an gott glauben
durchaus also solange sie verankert sind also
dass die verankerung wichtig ist aber dass es
nicht unbedingt gut sein muss dass für manche
menschen gott sehr wertvoll sein kann das steht
für mich außer frage das ist einfach hinzufügen
dass es nicht immer gut sein muss wir sind
leider schon am ende des gesprächs ich möchte
eine letzte frage an sie stellen und zwar hat
valentin abgottspon dessen der vizepräsident
der schweizer freidenker vereinigung in einem
radiointerview zur seelsorge gesagt er habe keine
seele und da gehe davon aus dass wir alle auch
keine seele haben und deswegen frau 1000 fr not
haben die denn eine seele ganz kurz so wie frau
note des foreign beschrieben hat schöner könnte
ich selber nicht formulieren dann würde ich eher
sagen ich habe keine seele ich bin seele so wie
sie das formuliert hat mit elektrischen ich das
kann ich nur übernehmen und sagen die im guten
sprechen denken genau wunderbar da haben sich
zwei gefunden vielen dank für das gespräch von
otpor 1000 mein kollege wolfram eilenberger
wurde vom peruanischen schriftsteller und
nobelpreisträger mario vargas llosa in seinem haus
nach madrid zum gespräch eingeladen das sehen sie
jetzt gleich in der sternstunde philosophie
einen schönen sonntag und des demnächst